i have a question actually this just
came out you can't answer it can't rip
unfortunately it's about brothers
so
how did
because you know obviously let's say
there's two two siblings or three
siblings in my house how was it decided
who gets which bedroom
ah
in your house that's a good question
well did you ever ask battle royale
squid game because i squid game i am the
middle son
and i got the tiniest room oh okay right
well i think for us we got lucky because
the house that i grew up in or i was
born in was like bought just
at the same time as they got that house
so i basically got first dibs right
because my sister wasn't born yet oh so
you got to choose i wasn't well i mean
no i wasn't like a three-year-old being
like father this room is a little larger
than the other one well you know what's
funny that's exactly what my parents
[ __ ] did really they asked me when i
was like two or whatever which room i
wanted
i cannot comprehend what i am doing
it's a big space either way right for a
kid yeah like this is fine this is great
i think i literally chose like the harry
potter club
and i'm like i'm like mom don't [ __ ]
believe what what two or three-year-old
connor cho why would you do that his mom
comes out with the contract is this this
you that's your name
did you sign you signed my blood
what the [ __ ] is this i would never
choose it you know i would have never i
got the room which was right next to my
parents room because obviously i was the
firstborn child right yeah and then my
sister got the last room which just so
happened to be next to the toilet
right right so i remember she would
complain being like you know because i
think our rooms were pretty much the
same size like it might have been minor
differences but it didn't really matter
it was it was roughly the same size but
i remember my sister used to complain
being like you know well at least you're
not [ __ ] in a room where like every
time someone has to take a [ __ ] in the
middle of the night you get woken up by
it and i was like uh
yeah okay well that sounds like you're
also you're closest to the toilet so
that's yeah exactly that's what i said
that's that's that's an advantage that's
right
yeah i'm wondering comments if you have
brothers and sisters or whatever
whatever how was it decided which room
was given to you can't relate or were
you all just shoved into one room can't
relate well actually yeah when my when
we were like really really little my
sister and i like you know obviously
just slept in the same room in the same
bed right and then yeah it's probably
maybe when i was like i don't know six
or seven that i finally got to pick one
of the rooms but like i don't remember
there being like a ritualistic [ __ ]
squid game of like well i wasn't
fighting to the death apparently i chose
this room which is do you remember
choosing the room no of course not i
don't know i don't ask my parents later
on i was like wait i chose it i'm like
why would you listen to me why
i don't i do i am not in the right mind
i cannot make good decisions yeah i mean
it was probably massive to you when you
chose it you know yeah yeah it was tiny
yeah like you could like there was no
place to put more than like a single bed
not that i would ever need more than i
said yeah if even if i wanted bigger
there's actually no space to put it
anywhere yeah and so it was just like
but of course you're talking about that
right like you obviously remember it
different to your parents all right so i
guarantee your parents are gonna
remember it and recall it differently
being like oh i specifically remember
connor [ __ ] volunteering as tribute
you know
they're like yes i will take the
smallest room for the family
going back to like weird events your
parents are taking you to so i remember
like i think the weirdest thing well not
the weirdest but the thing that sticks
out to my mind right now is my parents
or my mom once me once took me to a
meditation meetup okay i think it was a
meditation meet-up okay so
i think what happened to is so my mom's
like buddhist so you know as a buddhist
this was before like i became like a
monk or a kid monk or anything like that
um
so you know
sometimes you uh you pray or you
meditate for good karma and all that
stuff so sometimes my mom would go to
like these buddhist meetups or these
meditation meets up uh what you do at
this meetup is you go there and you
meditate for about an hour in like
darkness right okay um with a bunch of
other people or a bunch of other people
right so like i was about seven years
old when this happened right so i think
like at that at that time like there was
no one to take care of me at home or
something i don't know why but my mom
was like
gone you're coming with me uh we're
gonna meditate and she i remember her
framing it in a way where we're just
gonna meditate for a little bit like
like like five minutes or something
that's what it was in my head right i
didn't know how long i would be sitting
still for yeah at this meet up i thought
because i she told me how to meditate
and we do it for like 10 to like 15
minutes at most right that's what i
thought i was getting into so we get
there i remember like the guy the head
guy was just like hey thank you all for
coming um so we're gonna be uh sitting
here i'm going to hit the gong and uh
we're going to turn off the lights and
we're going to just sit here for an hour
and after the hours on i'm going to hit
the gong again android game every 10
nights
and so i remember thinking
what the [ __ ]
i've got to sit here in silence for an
hour
what i was seven years old i could i
couldn't like sit still for five minutes
let alone let alone the [ __ ] hour
like solving the god so i remember so i
remember like sitting down i'm like i'm
like [ __ ] panicking trying to figure
out how the [ __ ] i am going to sit here
for an hour i look over to my mom my
mom's just like already like [ __ ] in
the zone yeah she's she's already she's
long gone she's done it she's long gone
she's in another [ __ ] dimension right
now and so and so he hits and so he hits
the goal luckily they have a clock in
the room so you can see how much time
goes past now what you're meant to do
during meditation is like you are meant
to just clear your mind right the point
of an hour is that it shouldn't feel
like an hour because
to your mind it should be as empty as
possible so you shouldn't really feel
the passage of time or you should feel
it less than usual right that's that's
that's the entire like zone you're
supposed to get in with meditation um so
i remember all right i remember thinking
all right you got this you've meditated
for 15 minutes you can do an hour um and
i remember sitting there and to me i'm
like i think about 40 minutes has passed
let me sneak over at the clock i look
over five minutes has gone by i'm just
like oh [ __ ] i start [ __ ] sweating i
look i look around are you seeing the
clock in the dark huh it was like one of
the glow in the dark oh yeah with like
uh with like a luminescence that makes
it even harder not to look as a kid yeah
yeah
i want to look at the
so so i'm just like so i come up with
this five-head
five-head strategy right because i'm at
that point i was [ __ ] obsessed with
pokemon right so
yeah who wasn't so like i i remember
like back in the day i had like recorded
like an entire season of pokemon and
that was like my entire my only
entertainment so i had like watched this
vhs this recording of pokemon like
[ __ ] 10 20 times right
10 20 times so i think to myself how am
i going to get through an hour i got a
five hit idea what if i just watch
three episodes of pokemon in my mind
and just and if i watch three episodes
of pokemon in my mind an hour would have
passed right so
i remember so i remember this [ __ ]
serial experiments like
so i like i like escape into the castle
is this the metaverse
i like entered the metaphors in my mind
and i just started watching
i just started playing playing the
episodes of pokemon that i can remember
unfortunately i think some gaps were
missed off because i i remember like
watching in my mind yeah three episodes
looking at the clock and then and half
an hour had gone by so i'm just like
okay maybe time moves differently in my
life
so i think i i think i watch an entire
season of pokemon in my mind your mind
was just like all right cutting out all
the filler right now only the important
influence i think i got through an
entire [ __ ] season and then i finally
hear the gong and i'm like
i'm like thank [ __ ] and i remember
afterwards like
some of my mom's friends comes over to
her and be like well i'm like so
impressed with your son like how do you
sit there for an hour like my son can't
concentrate anything for five minutes
i'm like i'm so impressed with your son
and i'm just like
they don't know i just got they don't
know i just watched pokemon for an hour
while you are drenching and sweating
they're like how does that just what
does that say again
well ashley's about to get to the
indiegogo league at least you stopped at
the [ __ ] good point man
what the [ __ ] did you do that that's
insane this man literally opened up his
third eye by reciting pokemon in his
head
anime companies hate this one trick
to letting you re-watch the anime
that's the real secret to like reaching
enlightenment you don't empty your mind
you just watch an entire season you just
watch one piece in your mind and you
just reach enlightenment could you do
that now i could not do that now
i could watch a show and then couldn't
do that immediately after that well
because that was back in the day when
you were a kid and you had like that one
thing that you watched over and over oh
yeah yeah yeah you could just like
recite it like i remember i could
probably like recite the entire movie of
toy story or something in my mind just
because i had watched it so many times
i have some movies like that too i could
probably recite the entirety of pulp
fiction that's because i've seen it so
many [ __ ] times but right now
three and a half hour movie let's go if
you need to meditate for that long
when i need to meditate
you know what they call quarter pound
with cheese in france